hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to be
talking about the ache men test before
we get started i want to remind you to
please hit subscribe hit the bell icon
to get notifications to get a lot of
biology study videos so let's get
started with this one on the aikman test
this is actually a really old test okay
it was developed by a dutch professor
named christian aikman it was originally
published in 1904 the original
publication was in german uh christian
aikman um
eventually went on to actually win the
nobel prize
with another scientist for his
contribution to the discovery of
vitamins so that's kind of your fun
factoid for today
but specifically with the aikman test
which really has nothing to do with
vitamins uh it is
it has two other names by which it's
known one is the differential
coliform
test
and it's also known as the confirmed
e coli test or the infer or the
confirmed e coli count test
now before we jump into the purpose and
methods of the aikman test i just want
to remind you what we mean by coliforms
okay
so coliforms are rod shaped bacteria so
bacillus shaped
they are gram negative
[Music]
if you need a reminder of the difference
between gram-positive and gram-negative
cell walls then please check out my
video gram-positive versus gram-negative
bacteria
so coliforms are rod-shaped they're
gram-negative bacteria that can ferment
lactose and other sugars and they're
present in large numbers
in feces
not just human feces but like animal
feces in general
and so coliforms are important because
they can be used as a convenient
indicator for fecal contamination and
what we mean by that is if you have a
water source and it's been contaminated
by feces
then there will be there will be fecal
coliforms in the water so if you can
detect fecal contamination
sorry if you can if you can detect
fecal coliforms then you can know that
there was fecal contamination and there
could be other fecal bacteria other
fecal pathogens present as well
so just to kind of put this in
perspective you know i think we're used
to thinking of e coli of course some e
coli is pathogenic but certainly not all
e coli there's plenty of e coli that
does not cause any disease
so some e coli are pathogenic e coli are
a type of fecal coliform but there are
other types of fecal coliforms as well
and then of course there are also
coliforms that are not fecal i mean
they're they're not present in feces
but when we're talking about fecal
contamination
and fecal coliforms we're usually
thinking of things like e coli
klebsiella
enterobacter
and so forth
so these would be three major examples
of fegal columnars
so now that we understand what coliforms
are let's go back to talking about the
aikman test its purpose is to determine
if a water source has been contaminated
by
fecal
coliform
bacteria specifically from warm
blooded animals so either from humans or
from warm-blooded non-human animals and
this is based on the ability of the
bacteria to produce gas
when grown in glucose media at
46 degrees celsius
so this particular set
of
of circumstances
will
only allow gas production if there are
fecal coliform bacteria present from
warm blooded animals fecal coliforms
that may be present
in in cold blooded from cold blooded
animals or coliforms that are present
just like naturally in the environment
but not from feces
will not produce gas when grown in
glucose media at 46 degrees
so now let's look at the method
the method is to inoculate
a glucose
peptone
broth i will say that some um like
alternative or modified forms of the
eggman test will use a lactose peptone
broth
but i think the standard is glucose
peptone broth in a test tube that this
is really important that contains a
durham tube
so the durham tube is there to collect
gas if it's produced of course if
there's no production of gas you get a
negative result there'd be no gas in
that durham tube
this is what a durham tube looks like
you've got the larger test tube
that has that glucose peptone broth
and you have this small durham tube like
floating inside
and it is it is um
it'll basically kind of start out like
at the bottom of the tube
but
if when that media is inoculated and the
bacteria in it are producing that gas
that gas that we're looking for for a
positive inkman test
then that gas will begin to
create bubbles which i'm kind of drawing
here
and some of those bubbles from that gas
production
will
float into the durham tube
and actually cause it to like rise up
and be floating at the surface with gas
trapped inside of it
so that is why the durham tube is so
important is because it collects the gas
that you would not otherwise be able to
see
so first you have to inoculate the broth
in a test tube that contains a durham
tube then you have to incubate it for
over 24 hours at 46 degrees and again if
you've got
gas production that would be a positive
result and that is considered a
presumptive identification
so presumptive
uh
presumptive identification of e coli
means that we are
presuming that there is e coli
based on presence of gas in the durham
tube however it is not an absolute
certainty and so it must be followed up
with another test to actually
confirm
that e coli is present there are two
tests that one could use to make this
this con this conformation of the e coli
identification
and that is either the endo test
and or the citrate test
now i actually have separate full-length
videos on the indole test and a separate
full-length video on the citrate test
and even more full-length videos on lots
of other
microbiological tests and so definitely
remember to subscribe and check out
those other videos i've also started
posting
photographs or not photographs i guess
but pdfs with pictures
of the final notes board
and so if you want the link to that
please grab it in the video description
and you can find
basically pdf versions of all of my
forward notes so thank you for watching
biology professor subscribe and i will
see you next time for more awesome
biology lessons thank you for watching